it's been a little over 20 years since
we've been sailing the grand line with
Luffy and the straw hats in search of
that elusive treasure one piece it's
been a voyage full of adventure and
thrills and through their journey this
merry gang of pirates has forged new
friendships and rivalries experience
victories and loss as well as happiness
and heartbreak while one piece as a
general rule makes you crack up with
laughter or bubble with excitement
it does have some truly tragic moments
naturally some of these moments belong
to the straw hats or to major figures
who are part of a particular story arc
but the beauty of one piece is that it
reserves some of its best writing for
even the most minor figures characters
who are seemingly on the sidelines and
may not have much of an impact on the
overall plot for their story still
enrich our experience today we're
counting down the ten saddest moments in
the series that aren't just there to
make us cry but also serve as vehicles
for character development and story
progression all of which makes one piece
the wonder it is without further delay
let's get on with it
rise along
[Music]
raizou is safe these three words uttered
by inuarashi to Kinnaman carry the
weight of loyalties that go so deep they
can't be expressed in words
though a phantom island on the back of
an ancient elephant has just survived a
brutal invasion by jack the beasts like
pirates in pursuit of raizo
a ninja from the land of one oh he
certain those mink tribes hiding rise oh
but despite their protests he tortures
and poisons them with his search ending
in disappointment days later when
Kinnaman kanjuro and a young ward
monoski arrived in zou the straw hats
expect the minks to take out all their
anger on the visiting samurai from 102
they're shocked the minks tearfully
informed Kinnaman of rezo's presence on
the island and his well-being it's
revealed that the minks are allies of
the samurai and have admirably carried
out their responsibilities a great risk
to their own lives this moment of
Revelation isn't overtly sentimental but
is subtly moving a surprising little gem
in a series as rambunctious as one piece
[Music]
Jerrica
next up we have the moment when a Fisher
Tiger tells koala it's okay to cry as a
child scarred by her years as a slave to
the celestial dragons the young koala
had learned to wear a fake smile and
never shed a tear for fear of being
persecuted or killed even when she's
rescued by Fisher tiger and briefly
becomes a member of his son pirates she
struggles to embrace her newfound
freedom for the next three years the
creepy smile stays in place along with
her repeated vows to work tirelessly and
never cry there's no convincing her that
her life is hers and no one else's all
that changes when Fisher Tiger snaps
koala out of her fear using actions
rather than words that it's okay to cry
and show emotion when realization
finally hits the tears koala held back
for all of those years finally flow the
disturbingly cheerful smile finally
leaves her face and her first cry which
is full of as much despair as it is of
hope makes its a quietly powerful moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cockroach terrorize other gear
[Music]
despite his sunglasses and his girl gank
who insists he's hard-boiled it's
impossible to take this big bellied
manchild seriously at first but it turns
out the story behind that ridiculous
outfit isn't just serious it's seriously
sad signora Pink's clownish appearance
is a tribute to his dead son one day he
puts on for his wife Russian with their
relationship already strained by their
son's death Russian leaves pink among
finding out that he's a pirate or not a
banker as he'd actually claim to be
she's then involved in an accident and
ends up in a vegetative state a
shattered pink visits her in hospital
every day one day on impulse he puts on
a baby bonnet to coax a smile out of her
and to his great surprise he succeeds
that's the beginning of his
transformation a man brave enough to be
ridiculed by all for the smallest reward
and the briefest moment of happiness has
our respect key mosquito
yonder Matata
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kokumo data at number seven we have
white beards death the marineford
arc remains one of the most significant
arcs in one piece with its smorgasbord
of characters breathless action and
untold tragedy the events of marineford
are especially important for the impact
on Goofy's growth one of these events is
the death of white beard the strongest
pirate in the world and a giant among
men such as his power that it's only by
resorting to treachery that his
opponents can gain an advantage over him
and such is his legacy that right after
announcing the existence of one piece in
the upheaval it will brink
he died standing despite having
sustained 267 sword wounds 152 gunshot
wounds and 46 cannonball injuries
tragedy and romance blend to make white
beards death one of the most memorable
in one piece one of the saddest as well
[Music]
[Music]
that brings us to the death of another
mentor a father figure to chopper doctor
he looks an oddball quack with weird
hair who's more adept at harming
patients than actually healing them yet
behind his much ridiculed exterior lies
a man with a beautiful dream that even a
fatal illness can't kill call him stupid
for drinking poisonous soup just because
it was made by his naive protege or for
walking recklessly into the evil war
Paul's death trap but there's something
about a man who faces death with a smile
and a fool isn't how you describe him
when he look faces a firing squad he
reminds everyone that a man dies not
when he shot or felled by an incurable
disease but when he's forgotten the
doctor takes his own life with one of
his failed medicines after raising a
toast to a life well-lived it goes
without saying that this eccentric man
will forever be remembered by the people
and lives he touched
arigato yo super
[Music]
for this list first moment directly
involving a member of the straw hats
we have Robin's raw cry for help from
the top of Enys lobby taken hostage by
the cp9 in its hateful chief's pander
Robin turns on her crewmates when they
come to rescue her behind this rejection
is a fear of betrayal and a mistrust of
all born of the scars of a horrific past
Robin's the sole survivor of a tribe of
archaeologists killed for their ability
to read the forbidden Tana glyphs this
ability earned Robin a bounty as an
eight-year-old and the epithet devil
child making her a pariah and hunted
figure when the grown-up Robin met the
straw hats for the first time it was as
an adversary but in her time of crisis
she realizes that the bond she
reluctantly formed with them is
strangely hard to break looking into
their determined faces she gives voice
to her honest feelings for the very
first time in her life it's our first
glimpse of the real Robin in a moment
that stays with us for a very very long
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if an air of melancholy seems strangely
suited to Robin it's the last thing
you'd expect in the context of Brooke
but for all his fondness for song and
dance and ladies underwear the skeletal
soul king has been through an ocean of
sadness once a living breathing member
of the Rumba pirates he watched half of
his crewmates to come to a mysterious
ailment and the rest to the unknown
terrors of the Florian triangle he died
with them only to be revived by his
devil fruit powers and cursed to an
afterlife of solitude that was until he
became a valued member of Luffy's gang
50 years later there's this one moment
when Brooke playing Binks RK on the
piano during a celebration with the
straw hats takes us back to the last
time he sang the same song with the
rumba pirates a final hurrah before
death as the tune plays in this
flashback we see the cheerful crew fall
to their death one by one until Brooke
remains it's remarkable how this moment
uses one song to evoke a mood of pure
joy on the one hand and a deep sense of
loss and loneliness on the other
[Music]
shut up
ma da da more skosh mr. Sol struck down
by a debilitating disease that left him
an orphan and an outcast encaged his
heart in self-destructive anger
trafalgar law was never meant to survive
his childhood yet he did and he owes it
all to one man don quixote a rose in
ante AKA corazon law initially hates the
bumbling mute corazon with a vengeance
but through a series of events corazon
ends up earning da fees AIA by stealing
a devil fruit in order to save law from
his terminal illness even sacrificing
his life for the young boy while laws
life to this point has been a
never-ending cycle of tragedies the
moment he loses corazon is undoubtedly
his lowest point from his hiding place
behind a protective layer of silence
placed around in by corazon law can only
watch helplessly as his savior embraces
death with a full smile corazones final
stand against his ruthless brother and
his final words to law as well as law
silent screams make for such a powerful
scene that it has to take number three
on this list
not get a booklet yeah
[Music]
my mother Tice acoustic repair Omar you
got a running theme in one piece is
Brotherhood but Brotherhood isn't only
between men one of the most beautiful
depictions of the spirit of nakama is
the bond between the straw hats and
their first ship the going Mary Mary so
beloved and treasured that her soul
takes on a visible spirit form and gains
a human voice after it numerous
adventures together
there comes a time when the straw hats
must say goodbye such a decision can't
come easily especially for a group of
people who place connections of the
heart above all else and it leads up to
one of the crews biggest internal crises
in a fit of rage
ooh soap who has a special attachment to
the ship challenges luffy to a fight the
winner gets to keep Mary when he loses
who sought walks out on the crew this is
by far one of the most emotionally
bruising moments in the series rivaled
only by the equally poignant send-off
Mary gets a little bit later
watching the straw hats including rusev
in his soaking mask give Mary a Viking
burial and say their final goodbyes is
just impossible not to be moved by their
broken sobs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Big Brother to Luffy son of the infamous
gol D Roger a commander of the white
beard pirates and a handsome rogue ace
remains the series most charismatic
figure now we know him better it's
impossible not to root for him but the
joy that comes from watching him
narrowly escape execution swiftly turns
to sorrow as he dies at the hands of a
canoe to protect Luffy the gaping lava
hole in his chest makes such powerful
imagery it's no wonder it kind news one
of the most hated characters aces final
moments with a distraught Luffy his last
words of gratitude and white beard
silent tears will forever be cemented in
our hearts in the hundreds of episodes
that have since followed there hasn't
been a more tragic and impactful moment
yet whatever
boom are addictive yo guitar haha
so yeah 'we used a media and there we
have it the top ten saddest moments in
one piece can we ever get over them like
this video and subscribe to vinnie tube
for more content like this did any of
these moments make you cry comment below
and let us know I'll see you next time
on the next video
[Music]
you
[Music]